[Music]
however at this stage knowledge of the
thing is still not complete it must be
known not only from the standpoint of
the immediacy of being and
determinateness but also as essence or
inner being as self this occurs in moral
self-consciousness this is aware that
its knowledge is a knowledge of what is
absolutely essential it knows that being
is simply and solely pure willing and
knowing it is nothing else but this
willing and knowing anything else has
only unessential being that is not
intrinsic being only it's empty husk
in the same measure that moral
self-consciousness lets determine it
being Go free from the self so too in
its conception of the world it takes it
back again into itself finally as
conscience it is no longer the continual
alternation of existence being placed in
the self and vice versa it knows that
its existence as such is this pure
certainty of itself the objective
element into which it puts itself forth
when it acts is nothing other than the
self's pure knowledge of itself
in this short but dense paragraph 792
what we're seeing worked out not
completely because some of it's going to
wait until the next paragraph
particularly the dimension of action but
what we're seeing worked out here is the
second of the two other moments that
were mentioned in paragraph
790 and you know what were these two
moments well additional parts of the
massive historical dialectic of the
development of Consciousness in the
phenomenology so far so one of those was
what we just went through in 791 looking
at the realm of self-alienated
Spirit right and so that was a
significant portion of the phenomenology
and what we're going to be looking at in
this paragraph now 792.
is what comes directly after that the
section that is titled morality morality
right which is distinct from ethical
life uh the earlier section in the
spirit portion and there's a lot to say
here about what we're actually doing but
what we should remind ourselves of is
that in absolute knowing from the very
beginning of this section Hegel has been
telling us that really two really
important things and then a third thing
that we're going to get to later which I
might leave a little bit
undefined because I don't want it to be
a spoiler but maybe we'll talk about it
so what is the first thing well all of
the
developments are essentially finished
we've gone through all of these sections
with Consciousness very abstract and
then self-consciousness which was kind
of an interesting jump a little bit more
concrete you know we start getting away
from just life itself and
self-consciousness and its meaning and
the Master Slave dialectic and
interstoicism skepticism and unhappy
Consciousness then we get into the the
massive reason section we talked about
that with observing reason but there's
more going on in there as well
and then we get to the spirit section
even longer you could say even more
stuff going on
relatively more concrete than the
earlier sections a little bit more let's
say historical right and then we get to
religion which is also a big faction and
a rather schematic in how Hegel develops
the different kinds of religion right
but leading ultimately up to
Christianity and then uh the overcoming
uh representation or picture thinking
foreshelling and then we get to Absolute
knowing so so the heavy lifting you
could say has been done already up to
this point and now what we're doing is
we're actually looking back
retrospectively at some of these
sections just a selection as you notice
and we could raise all sorts of
interesting questions why those are not
these instead and we'll talk about that
in a bit and uh we have to retrace the
steps that Spirit as Consciousness as
self-consciousness as the hopefully soon
reconciliation of Consciousness and
self-consciousness which by the way was
talked about in the very beginning of
the religion section wasn't it and
towards the end of it as well
all of this has to be re
reworked but not too much you notice
that Hegel is rather summery and you
know this leads us to the uh very
important conception of aufhaven this
sublation or transcending well
preserving the important moments of that
which you're effectively leaving behind
or leaving in the background the
development the previous stuff and then
you know we could talk about a third
thing I mean would it be properly
hegelian if we didn't have a Triad here
we could joke around a little bit about
that and say the key in absolute knowing
is to have a knowing of knowing a
knowing of what it is that Spirit has
been up to to this point what we as the
phenomenologists readers following along
with Hegel the phenomenologist
writer and thinker have before us as
achievements of spirit or mind up to
this point now it's time to actually
assimilate those and integrate them
which hopefully you know we do by the
end we still have quite a few paragraphs
of this section this last section of the
phenomenology to go and we should remind
ourselves too that the phenomenology as
Hegel intends it at the time is not the
absolute end of his systematizing or
even of his system right we have further
books that are going to come about we
have additional developments even we
could say in the lectures that cover
some of the same ground as we saw for
example when thinking about the religion
section uh Hegel fills in quite a few
interesting gaps okay so that's enough
preface right there about what this you
know what the overall task is for this
section now let's zero back in on this
particular paragraph
so he tells us however at this stage at
what stage well the stage that we're
moving into next which is going to be
looking at moral self-consciousness and
conscience right so we're leaving behind
the well are we leaving behind yes and
no these other
stages or rather shapes of Consciousness
that we have now traversed several times
and again if you permit me a little bit
of a digression before jumping straight
into the text itself we should realize
that the structure of the phenomenology
is not purely linear
right it's not as if we putting aside
the preface which is its own uh
whole can of worms and talking about you
know the introduction okay the
introduction's kind of interesting as an
introduction nice and short easy to
grasp we have Consciousness and then
these three stages within it you know as
we see right here is uncertainty
perception force and the understanding
uh then we have self-consciousness with
two of its uh sections there then we
have the whole reason section so when we
go through the Consciousness section for
example
we do so at the start and we do so in
great detail right and there's all sorts
of surprises along the way that's part
of the dialectical process we start out
with oh I think this is the way it is we
finally reached our stable finish point
and now we understand things and then
Hagel says what let me pull the rug out
from underneath and things get more
complicated so we make it through that
does that mean that it's over I mean it
might seem that way given the abrupt
jump between uh Consciousness and
self-consciousness
as a number of people have pointed out
the transitions between these massive
sections or portions of the work are not
all that
necessary to use a term Hegel loves to
bring up you know there's not a there's
not as much if there is a necessity or
not vendi kite to this transition from
one to the next uh Hegel doesn't do a
super job in making it completely
explicit
however
what we see
is that at multiple points in the work
we've got the previously
traversed dug through section
and it does get sublated brought into at
a higher level both of abstraction and
of context and meaning other sections so
hey Google reference back to the
previous section most notably in the
very beginning of religion where he says
that all four of these threads are drawn
together into a not right and we do see
the sun certainty perception force and
the understanding getting rehearsed
again just earlier in paragraph 789
right so we can say the same thing with
a lot of these other sections we're
going back over them and each time we do
it it's sort of like listening to a
musical composition we notice more or
traversing a landscape going along a
trail we see more than we saw the
previous time I think the music one is
probably better in part because we're
not bringing in you know the seasons or
stuff like that and how things change
going from Spring to Summer to fall to
winter be that as it may so let's talk
about what we've got here so we've
already in the you know last so 789 to
traversed these sections uh and we've
we've brought them up we've remembered
them to use the phrase that Hegel used
before so the Consciousness section
explicit reference to sense certainty
which we're also going to see uh here
you know soon perception right the thing
that comes after that and then they're
very complicated difficult understanding
meaning force in the understanding and
the various worlds that are involved so
far so good right
and then we jump right into observing
reason which is the first part of the
reason section okay that makes perfect
sense we don't interestingly talk about
in this uh summary we don't talk about
the other portions of reason right
namely section B the actualization of
rational self-consciousness through its
own activity which includes some pretty
important ethical stuff right or
individuality which takes itself to be
real in and for itself which gives us
the spiritual animal kingdom then the
very cotton fused reason is law give or
Reason is testing laws
um we're leaving that aside and
similarly we're not referencing the
self-consciousness section here which
you know is pretty big pretty important
notice that Hegel doesn't think we need
to talk about that as we're traversing
remembering these previous shapes of
Consciousness at this point and then we
get self-alienated spirit so we don't
get the whole Spirit section right he's
not beginning with the whole Antigone
Dynamic at the beginning of the spirit
section the true Spirit the ethical
order right
we're jumping right into section B
self-alienated Spirit culture right and
what do we get in there we get culture
and the
realm of actuality not talking about
that what we do get is the dialectic of
faith and pure Insight but really just
talking about pure inside and then we
get the enlightenment uh but what else
don't we get absolute freedom and the
terror why is that passed over well uh
maybe we don't need it at this point for
where we're going so we should think
about where we are going we're going to
be now talking about moral
self-consciousness right so more Alicia
or the morality morality section which
does lead into ultimately conscience not
just conscience in that section right
that is where we encounter more uh bits
and pieces the Beautiful Soul evil and
its forgiveness which we're going to
talk about in uh the the paragraphs to
come actually right after this paragraph
So Ian just hold on to that right so
what does he have to say about about
this particular section
at this stage
knowledge vision of the thing the the
you know the the ding is still not
complete it's not full lend it not
perfected not brought to its fruition
it's not complete uh not in the sense of
like ticking off boxes but not complete
in the sense of a full and complete
development that integrates everything
together
why not
well now here with this contrast
we have the we have a sort of a
backwards reference to what went on in
the previous paragraphs right just think
about uh what went on in 791 towards the
end
um you know talking about sense
certainty to be absolute truth but this
being for self is itself declared to be
a moment that merely vanishes and passes
over into its opposite why because it's
empty it's it's uh nothing into a being
that is at the disposal of another being
for another right so that's on this side
the immediacy the unmittal bark height
of being zein and determinantness
taking on characteristics particular
characteristics the knowledge of the
thing is partly knowing that side of it
you could call this as hegel's going to
it's it's shell it's outer right and
then what do we have on the other side
as we go into it now remember too as we
talk about this we're not just talking
about the thing as the external thing of
observing reason we're thinking about
ourselves
and spirit itself
and history as the thing so what do we
got on the other side Essence these
what is important what is Central
what it really matters what has meaning
it's inner being
right so that's important as well and
both of these are involved as he says
self zelfst and he says this occurs in
moral
self-consciousness not just moral
Consciousness although you know could
you actually have just moral
Consciousness from a hegelian
perspective you could certainly have
ethical Consciousness uh watching what
somebody else does or seeing the
consequences of your behavior and having
some sort of
affective value response oh that's good
or that's bad right
but to
grasp your action your willing your
comportment your character as your own
as belonging to a self
there has to be
self-consciousness and I'd like to
actually pause another slight digression
I've said this many times throughout
this commentary on the phenomenology
Hegel is a great speculative theoretical
thinker
but for him
Consciousness self-consciousness reason
Spirit these are not merely abstract
theoretical sorts of matters we are
always
Spirit within the world a world in which
we act and suffer and engage others and
compare and contrast and justify or
sometimes don't justify and feel bad as
a result so moral self-consciousness in
a certain way is
is more self-consciousness than just the
you know abstract well
self-consciousness always exists in
relation to another self-consciousness
from the self-consciousness
section
you know there is something that got uh
brought up over and over again in the
reason section in these portions that
we've left out here at this point
the
project or the thing that matters most
right the ethical project the which
transforms into the moral project over
time so what is moral self-consciousness
do what is it consistent according to
Hegel he tells it this is now here's a
little a little bit of a quibble about
translation this is a where no it's not
aware it knows Vice that's the word that
Hegel actually uses here Vice vison it
it this is its knowledge at work right
so it knows
that it's knowledge
is of what is absolutely
essential absolutely
these and height not Mason as such vase
and height what is essential what bears
essentiality what you know the condition
of being essential so moral
self-consciousness isn't just knowledge
or uh self or consciousness of the
dimensions of the self that you know are
we could say trivial or don't matter
you might think I'm not saying that this
is conscient at this point I'm just
using Kant as an example and we could
use Thomas Aquinas as an example or
Anselm as an example for this sort of
thing as well when Kant says if you're
going to act consider the maxim that
you're acting on what is a maxim it is a
rule but also a descriptor for what the
hell you're doing
what it is that you're contemplating and
being drawn to or being repulsed by this
is what you know Thomas Aquinas would
frame in terms of the moral species or
ethical species type of an Act Right the
maxim determines that and and I
determine that in my own action with my
moral self-consciousness
knowing what the essential thing is
about what I'm doing
if I go and give food to a beggar what
kind of action is that really we have to
describe it properly and I brought up
Anselm you see him doing this over and
over again in his Works
um proper description of what is of the
essence of the action from a moral
perspective that is involved in moral
self-consciousness so that's part of its
knowledge right
going on what else does it know it knows
as Hegel is going to tell us here
um so it's aware its knowledge is a
knowledge of what is this absolutely
essential or order it knows that being
is solely and simply so it's not as if
there's two different terms there in the
German uh pure Reina willing and knowing
right so he says
it's interesting here that that Miller
changes the ore to to you know
um
something slightly different here right
simply and solely pure willing and
knowing
well it's really simply and solely pure
willing and or knowing right
Odom there now does this matter much I
mean
I think that what there's a disjunction
that's happening there and I actually
think that the or makes these things a
little bit closer you can look at it
this way or you can look at it this way
but really these are both intimately
connected with each other and then he
doesn't say that it knows this but I
think that we can put this under the
aspect of knowledge that it namely moral
self-consciousness is nothing else
than this willing and knowing right
anything else as he says has only an
essential being not intrinsic being only
it's empty husk
that's this that is the immediacy of
being and determinedness right that is
the uh nothing or the emptiness that we
saw mentioned in the previous paragraphs
I think right
so this is what moral self-consciousness
is bringing to the table and hopefully
something that all of us at this stage
of the dialectic possess and now can
think about and then we go on to yet
another part of this this is all part of
the moment that this paragraph is
bringing up that was referenced back in
790.
so he says um
well before he says that he says
um in the same measure that moral
self-consciousness lets determinate
being
Go free from the self so too in its
conception of the world it takes back
takes it back into itself
so you know it thinks uh the terminate
being is who I am right I think of
myself
we might even think about the
self-alienation that's overcome here
right
I think of myself as the person who
knows Wills does feels
um hopes for pick up whatever modality
you want in determinate ways
and then I abstract from that and then I
come back to it again
and then we get to conscience
he says finally
as conscience
now notice what happens here we have an
integration
it is no longer this continual
alternation of existence
being placed in the self and vice versa
you know the translation there Miller's
translation is getting a little bit away
from the German because what he says is
excellent then right so alternation
works there or exchange right vexilum is
exchange
to put something down in place uh to
establish something fishdalen is very
close to four stellen representation but
it's not representation right so
um
almost like a little uh rhyme there and
it's talking about the relationship
between the self and
designer existence being there right
Heidegger's term but Hegel uses it in
that sense as well
so uh it is no longer this continual
alternation of existence being placed in
the self it knows that its existence as
such as zolke is this pure certainty of
self and again we want to look at the
what's actually being said here Aina
pure gevis Heights yes certainty right
and notice that gives height and gavis
and very very close together as we
remark back in that section
so certainty of self certainty of its
very own self zeiner zelst right
a little bit more intensified there
conscience when it's genuinely
conscience is telling you who you are
and what you're doing and the meaning of
it right it's part of it's a growth out
of moral self-consciousness so he says
the objective element into which it
what is it conscience puts itself forth
when it acts
notice we finally have gotten to action
here handling to behave to comport
oneself to act not just uh in terms of
uh doing one thing but meaningful action
we could say now we have uh knowledge
and willing and action the things that
go together in the morality section over
and over again when it acts is nothing
other than the self's pure knowledge of
itself
that's a very interesting way to end
isn't it
when it acts when it doesn't just will
but that will moves out into the messy
world of human beings and our desires
and consequences and all of that that
sort of stuff that ethical action
involves
now it becomes as he says the self-pure
knowledge of itself now we could read
this as oh it suddenly becomes abstract
but we could also read it as this is how
the self-pure knowledge of itself
transforms itself into something that
has existence has Dasa and has being in
the world and has determinate meaning
for the one who is engaging in it
we should remind ourselves of one other
thing before we we close this off and
get ready for the next paragraph which
is going to consolidate these matters
what did we see in these sections
morality and and conscience
well
um
the morality section is actually one of
the most interesting portions of the
phenomenology for me in part because
when we look at action that is supposed
to be moral
we see there's so many different
components to it so many different
dimensions to it and you can get this
right but get this wrong or in the very
process of focusing on this you overlook
this over here nothing like that is is
present in the resolution that's taking
place here but that remains within the
background
we can never do morality mechanically
you could say
we have to always be present as thinking
as knowing as willing
beings so that's
arguably what's going on in this short
little paragraph you see that there's
quite a lot involved just in what we're
looking at here and now we have
traversed once again these important
portions of the phenomenology that we
previously looked at in much greater
detail